what you're looking at is a population pyramid
for the european union it shows the percentage
of the population at different stages of life the
percentage of people within the retirement bracket
the people that are of working age that support
the elderly population through their taxes and
the youngest ranging from late 20s to teenagers
and children a population pyramid is one of the
most robust visuals for understanding society
because it's one of the clearest for identifying
a particular stage of development in a country
this pyramid shows that europe's fertility rate is
declining the share of europe's population that is
old is increasing and the share of the population
that is young is declining and i think it needs
to be abundantly clear to people why continued
quick decline in fertility rates is a problem
and why it's a particular problem for europe
societies move through demographic stages stage
one is when death and birth rates are both high
pre-industrialization this was the reality for
most of human society throughout history stage two
is when death rates begin to fall but birth rates
remain high general standards of living improve
which reduces the death rates but high fertility
still seems economically useful the more children
the more potential providers when you're older
stage three is when birth rates also begin to
play catch-up this is usually the result of
children having a lower benefit than they used to
and improvements in women's position in society
reducing the demand for them to bear children
where europe and the rest of the
developed world are is around stage four
death rates are low and birth rates are also low
and around one half of the world's population
lives in countries below the fertility rate
that would keep their populations constant
europe has a 1.53 fertility rate and without
including migration europe would be experiencing
a population decline what will come after stage
4 is unclear death rates will probably stay low
what will happen to fertility is
something we still need to figure out
some say it will increase back to around 2.1
the replacement fertility while others paint a
bleaker picture that birth rates will continue to
decline the logic is relatively simple old people
cost money and europe is going to have a lot of
them the key measure here to understand is the
old age dependency ratio the amount of working
age people that support a single elderly person
most european state pension systems have a
large part coming from a pay-as-you-go system
which means the retirement benefits of the current
retirees are being financed by the people who are
currently working with the expectation that future
generations will finance you when you're older
over the next couple of decades as the amount of
old people increases in europe and the amount of
young people reduce the dependency ratio will push
pension expenditures to increase for every person
in the eu older than 65 years old in 2019 there
were almost three people aged between 20 and 64.
by 2040 this ratio would fall to just two
decreasing further to 1.7 people of working
age for every person older than 65 years old in
2070. old people carry costs much like incredibly
overweight people do you have a pool of insurance
money that is spent when a person requires medical
assistance increase the amount of people in that
pool that have a higher likelihood to need medical
assistance and you can expect the insurance money
to need to rise in turn what makes this situation
more uncomfortable is that the stage of future
developments in health technology is relatively
uncertain if we were to just account for the age
increases we can expect public health expenditure
in the eu to grow from 6.6 of gdp to 7.7 however
if we saw an increasing life expectancy with
little to no gains in health status for the old
we could imagine it becoming even more expensive
people matter because people produce and
people at different stages of their life
produce in different amounts although
it might be potentially a taboo topic
a declining share of the population that is young
may put more pressure on the relevancy of europe
and this video i can assure you will not be
the only place you'll see making this argument
europe is the oldest continent on average
and its share of global gdp is declining
there really aren't any perfect solutions to this
problem you can make older generations work longer
boost migration to increase the labor force and
incentivize europeans to have more children but
each of these solutions comes with their own
set of difficulties in 2019 macomb tried to
raise the pension age from 62 to 64. however when
mccomb took actions to increase the retirement age
which would have reduced the burden on the taxable
class in the future this wasn't taken lightly
another potential solution that's
much less controversial is migration
need more people that can support the elderly
population just bring in more workers but there's
a trade-off here and there will probably not be
enough migration to make a serious enough dent in
the trajectory towards an aging european society
also the impacts of migrants is relatively unknown
it's not that migrants wouldn't have any impact
on the burden of social programs but in the same
way that improving health technology is
something that we can't exactly predict
the marginal benefits of a specific migrant
and their associated impact on the tax base
is also relatively unknown in addition arguing
about whether migrants should or should not be
encouraged to enter the european union is also
a relatively useless discussion because europe
might not even be in a position where they can get
enough migrants to make a noticeable impact on the
old age dependency ratio in the first place there
are other countries out there that are also facing
the same problems and they will also be in the
market for labor force that can boost the overall
tax base and reduce a deficit that's also why it
should be of no surprise that the eu is reforming
their migration policies in order to attract more
highly skilled workers through making things like
their blue card initiative which is basically
european green card more generous europeans also
intimately understand that increasing support for
larger inflows of migrants is probably politically
infeasible and could legitimize critiques by the
european electorate who are concerned that they've
delegated too much authority to an institution
that removes their ability of choosing who they
want to come into their country or not higher
shares of older populations are associated with
anti-eu votes and although the literature has been
mixed on this richards by the european commission
itself has reported that there is an association
between the presence of migrants from outside of
the eu in a respective anti-eu vote obviously the
anti-eu sentiment can be mediated by the skill
level of the migrant but it does put the european
union in a potentially uncomfortable scenario
reduce some of the pressure on its social programs
by bringing in an external labor force but risk
anti-establishment sentiment in 2019 victor orban
unveiled his family protection action plan which
would give potentially thousands of euros to
women who give birth to enough children offering
30 000 euros of interest-free loans that would be
canceled upon the birth of a woman's third child
although seemingly popular among orban supporters
and also weirdly among conservative pundits in
the united states just injecting money and hoping
to produce babies is more difficult than it seems
and will probably take a while before we see any
long-term impact assuming that these policies
will make a significant dent there's also an
important question about which one comes first
interest-free loans of 30 000 are by no means
cheap so can they work in time to offset the
additional costs an increasingly older population
will produce to find an answer to that question is
a matter of time the reason why europe may face
a larger problem with its dependency ratio than
a country like the united states besides the
fact that the us is younger generally is that
the eu's legitimacy is still more precarious as a
political institution the eu schengen area made it
possible for europeans to move between borders and
is seen as an overall net positive but the ability
for europeans to move freely between borders may
also exasperate pressures on the countries that
are facing an increasingly older population rural
regions continue to decline in population while
urban regions continue to grow and this phenomenon
does not just happen within countries but
more importantly concerning the stability of
the entire european union it happens between
countries within europe as there is an outward
migration of younger people to urban centers
due to better economic opportunities central and
eastern european countries will continue to face
even more demographic pressure that can weaken
their economic growth and social support systems
and when that happens enough for a long enough
time that people get increasingly concerned
about their younger neighbors leaving for better
economic opportunities elsewhere the ramifications
for the political institution that seems like
it is accelerating that process can be huge
you